Let's see.
Uh, let's go to our caller from the three
one, two area code.
Who's calling today from three one, two.
Hello? Yes.
Hi.
Uh, is, uh, Hugh from Illinois.
Hey, how's it going?
I have a sub.
The subject I want to bring up is about greater
Thumper.
You just won the person of the year for time
right now.
Right.
And there's the questions I have is like a
two parter.
I dunno if it was inspired, inspired by Trump
or I don't know, whatever else, but the way
that she's been treated in the internet is
kind of just worrisome of how people just
talk about this girl.
I just, the first question is why do you think
people treat her that way?
And the second question is, uh, why did time
make her personally a year?
So let's deal with the second part first.
I, my sense I don't, I'm not saying she didn't
deserve it or she did deserve it.
I think the whole concept of person of the
year on a planet with 7 billion people is
a dubious concept anyway.
But let's ignore that for a second.
I've always perceived that time has a sense
of humor or a sense of satire or a sense of
trolling when they do person of the year.
So part of me does suggest, you know, Trump
has made a huge deal out of, he's lied about
the number of times he's been on the cover
of time.
For example.
I kind of get the sense that there's a little
bit of a, let's trigger Trump element, uh,
of selecting gratitude Berg as person of the
year.
Um, you know, we, every year there are probably
millions of people that are your, certainly
tens of thousands that would be a strong contender
for person of the year, many of which we'll
never hear about because we have a country
of, you know, planet of 200 countries and
7 billion people getting closer and closer
to, to 8 billion people.
Now, as far as the treatment of Gretta online,
it's absolutely disgusting.
I mean you're, you're talking here about,
first of all, you're talking about a kid.
Now you can say, well, it's a kid, but she's
choosing to be in the public eye and she's
doing things to get attention and therefore
there is going to be reaction and the reaction
that people are allowed to evaluate what she's
doing.
Sure.
Evaluate what she's doing on the facts, evaluate,
you know, the merits of what she's trying
to do.
But, you know, making fun of her for being
autistic either implicitly or explicitly is
a big theme that I see online and it's absolutely
disgusting.
Um, ridiculing, um, her demeanor, uh, we're,
we're talking about someone who, even if you
don't agree with her about the facts about
the ice caps, right.
We are talking about someone who has the best
intentions and is a kid in the end and it
is disgusting what you see happening online
about her.
Yeah.
And I see a lot of, uh, a big subject that
everybody brings up whenever they try to trash
on her is that it's our parents that like
pay everything and just use her as opposed
to as opposed your child for the whole movement.
Well, who's going to pay for as a kid?
Most kids don't have their own money.
Yeah.
And it's just, you think that's justifiable
that like if her parents really coerced her
into doing, into being the, this symbol for
climate change or,
I mean, listen, coerced.
I don't know what that means.
There's no question.
You know, my politics and my interests have
been heavily influenced by those of my parents.
Did they coerce me?
No.
Did they encourage me to do things?
I showed an interest in, of course.
[inaudible] the idea that a Gretta tune Berg
is essentially a slave held hostage by her
parents to do climate activism seems laughable.
There's no question that she got into this
because of her parents.
That's sort of how life works.
If you're connected to your parents and they're
raising you in a home where where you talk
and are involved with each other.
Again, it's just people are really looking,
people are very triggered by her [inaudible].
They start doing things that make very little
sense.
Yeah.
That's why I was like, thanks for the answer.
Did I?
Yeah.
I don't know.
It just has me worried.
Hi.
So I just need to, I need some kind of voice
of reason.
Alright.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate the phone call very much.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up because we
are going right back to the phones after this
very, very short break